però sta succedendo quello che temevo
cioè si sta chiudendo
ciao amici dopo ma dove siamo
siamo a casa mia come questo tram
godetevi questo sfondo perché tra un po
non c'è per la cena grazie a mamma cari
tornati su gesto quello del dove deve
indovinare le cose di oggi ci focus
siamo focalizziamo concentriamo dire
sentire focus è ormai siamo tutti
internazionale cio ci fu possiamo
sull'italia italia italia in italia noi
siamo nati in italia non so se anche voi
allora ragazzi questo è chiaramente ma
la mia allora se voi conosceranno
palermo palermo
se voi riconoscete la vostra città
ditecelo nei commenti
esatto perché ci interessa assolutamente
sì però dimmi tu conosci sudamericani
sospettano viterbo dove scritto viterbo
vita incredibile viterbo i termini
grazie veri che scrivono i nomi delle
città io adesso 90 sempre dall esame
viterbo tosta viterbo
[Musica]
ciao mamma bari 20 mar
e dove resta a viterbo vedi pure lui che
la prima 4 allora ci rivela 6 3 6 3
viterbo e provincia di ancona veramente
convinto nord ovest nord o nord e centro
italia nord ove sono di vicinato in
emilia romagna non è nordovest ma per
favore che vi daremo vita allora potrò
mai visto mamma mia
grazie raga va bene 798 metri si fa una
bella lotta ma si aspetta che capiscono
i cartelli carta di bisogno c'è scritto
qua siamo ok teatro toselli cuneo cuneo
eccolo cielo dove alcune facciamo schifo
però incredibile non è che uno schifo
veramente non ci credo solo perché in
piemonte lo seguiva da equa e vc però
aspetta una nuova o cuneo vecchia nuova
porca vacca è un chilometro da più
vicino a scuole o nuova minuti a piedi
era come un vecchio invece va beh milano
c'è mi milano il 15 d'agosto madonna
raga colombia con un ma grande baia
località di due stupidi così davanti a
casey è come se ci avvisasse
qualcos'altro bagheria e non possiamo
come fare magari ha preso meglio la foto
colombaia madonna sta poteva scattare
nel 1601 dalla macchina poi appoggio
pieni meglio l'ictus poggio le cose oggi
lo sa di un nome toscano non so perché
non ho mai sentiti toscanini un appoggio
e i siri
alexa dove appoggio l'italia
toscana mettiamola in toscana poi vabbè
ma comunque può essere una città questo
non c'è niente dove voglio vivere qua io
voglio vivere qui den qui qui cambiato
incredibilmente giorgia ma qui c'è tipo
tynset di mais esistenza ecco che io
voglio vivere qua sai quante rotture di
palle in meno generalità compero però
internet celaya però in lombardia
c'entra niente né in lombardia scritto
l'hanno fregato d'appoggio il cartello
che se c'era di fuga in lombardia tutto
questo è possibile fare allora
bene allora allora quindi città una
bella città città ci sono gli archivi a
roma viene posta a roma perché ne vai
nelle stradine voi nel vialone grande
nella strada
si ok qui alone grande cerchiamo
qualcosa che ho una rotonda 15 saranno
cartelli
eccoli eccoli eccoci a milano vercelli
stazione biella san paolo a milano
milano per cellino e in piemonte a
biella biella sanpaolo biella è sempre
abbiamo anche molto il river biella via
biella
ok la stazione di biella qua ma dopo era
però è tenera con il vialone che ci
aspetta esattamente qui vai
clicca
[Musica]
voglio vedere quattro metri la barriera
attualmente lo sputo design per terra
tre volte si è già incredibile perfetto
ragazzi mi piace al video non merita
allora di nuovo trick di prima sentiti
prima quindi che questa è la strada
principale di questa città concerto è
pronto e un pronto soccorso però queste
sicilia cento per cento mi dispiace di
queste cose fatto sei siciliana che non
ha dato un fattivo degli posso dire lo
dico per i miei amici sapete bene che
comunque il pattern e delle strade che
abbiamo giù il pattern nel sacco
esistono e questo comunque a me ogni
volta in sicilia cioè a me piace come
tutti anche un bel clima
ci sono delle persone no e sicilia 6 la
cosa come questa va dal bambino mandino
al four con la combo del vecchio in
mezzo alla strada si tira benissimo lui
fatto questa qua e karachi una mappa di
enugu due sì però anche in favelas
all'inizio phd catania tutti cerca di
paesini biancavilla
ma non c'è in pokémon si brucia
biancavilla grandissimo se vado lì e non
mi parte la musica mi girano biancavilla
marial cavill qua a morire ok siamo in
via redipuglia
tuttavia creature sarebbero
quando libro non la vedo aspetta ce n'è
uno con un'ala forse aveva intuito sé
stante ok non è una rotonda mi sa di sì
di puglia sta roba
grazie a non è la puglia e lombardia
festa
ottima media in toscana non ci voglio
credere
oggi poi si fugge bones i ragazzi io la
toscana e belli mesi massi punto io
allora io mi trasferirò anche lì anche
l'ici vivere io vincere se vi dicessi
domani andiamo lì dove vado lì e non sto
scherzando
pronto costante poi ci portano
complimenti signor dottore macchine per
cucire macchine per cucire mt ma la
domanda è dove eravamo invitati
no computer vabbè dai facciamo burroughs
massi la maledizione se fanno da 4 a 8
metri brama mia in credito con i
trattori delle esatte bene per cucine
macchine per cucire ma basta credibile
che cosa guarda quant'è bello che in
casa di strettino il ritiro di patenti
altro tiro dalla os30 mezza però visto
era in trentino non è il trentino della
val d'aosta mi dai
donzelli famosissima ma senza ritegno
aspetti ma lo sai sardegna con nino
nostra mensa che c'è scritto proprio
sindaco lapenna fida di me parla guarda
iniziano sarda ma gli inglesi moore lugo
la ue è tutto sardo sardegna o che lei è
sarda c'è scritto qua c'è scritto daje
tutto tutto solito sindaco di iglesias
ecco ecco qua inglesi al sestetto
paesino come incredibili quello di
essere sta qua io c'entro lo chiedesse
di inglesi avevano mandati qui in questo
preciso punzi seguito in cui quadro però
siamo nel centro 9 dic ora però noi
eravamo suonati sicuro libro me
ammazzare anche un po più qua ma se
questo il suo e noi siamo qui e qui dai
metter via l'acqua fa male un m 16 ti
sdrai l'hai preso tra l'altro pochettino
visione madonna
mamma mia ma cos'è europea qua ci vuole
andare
questo e tropea rosa in qui si azzecca
madonna ha giocato un minuto in minuto
quando sono uscito
mettiti roberts non basta non guardiamo
niente perché tropea se succede questa
cosa lo fai
ci sono tutto voi come lo fai tropea
perché non so neanche dove sia che non
lo so ecco che curò vai bro ma allora
aspetta la c'è quella quella cunetta
non ci voglio credere
71 metri tutto qui io i miei voti
geografia sono falsati falsate forte
sono falsati incredibile
possiamo concludere qui ragazza abbiamo
definito la nostra bravura la mia
profili geografia non mi con anche come
si sa però almeno io vero oggi sarai
questo rosso desistere contentissima di
questo risultato i ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto ringrazio il buon gianpi
c'erano prossimo video iscrivetevi a
mente campanella
procediamo il prossimo vi do as tropea
domani ci vediamo domani trovare bella
ragazza
[Musica]